oh we had quite the episode be quite
yesterday breaking down saying I don't
know what to talk about and we had to
wait were you off we got Jake Paul Nate
Diaz recap we break that down yeah
talk about that who has more pressure
going into the fight oh yeah we'll talk
about a Little Love is Blind game that's
fine but John Davidson's uh brush oh we
talk about his brothers cannoli yeah yep
yep he said it's not that big
we beg to differ yeah you're talking
about the Ukraine war guys if you want
to learn about politics and Science and
you know journalism and the big
questions UFOs Star Nation we ain't the
people yeah this isn't it we ain't got
the wrong page but like subscribe right
now if you want to laugh your weiner off
wiener off there it is there's another
dong joke
a little around 56.
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
you know what man we're gonna do a
podcast once again for the 1 000th time
and I'll tell you something you always
find something to talk about today I
looked at you and I went my mind's a
blank before we aired you went what are
we gonna talk about yeah let's just be
real clear you're an hour late right
well let's not get an hour late I'm an
hour late we're supposed to start at 11
30. 12 30. I forgot to charge my Tesla
and you called my car and I say it you
called my car this is another
no that's just a term well it doesn't
mean that car likes the same size it's
just me it's the word we used to use for
things where it it should be yeah I
should be it shouldn't be used for men
who like men or women like women it
should be used for it's a car yeah it's
just like it's like it's not cool yeah
which doesn't mean being it's not cool
that's right I love how we've become so
woke well you definitely have which is
bumming me out but you're you send me
that video of you you're not charging
your Tesla or you
charge my Tesla no but that's reason
1000 why you shouldn't buy a Tesla it
doesn't I've never got my car like oh
man it's not gonna make it there because
I didn't charge it well how stupid is
that I had to I had to precondition the
battery you put in where you want to go
and then you go to the charging station
okay you don't have one at the house and
I waited I I had I took because I knew I
was going to be late and it was going to
take me I could have been here at 11 30.
I could have risked it but then I would
have been at five percent battery and I
would have to find a place it gets dicey
because now you got a job
is there like a triple A you called a
charger for you there's not you gotta
there's no like toad to these in charge
of God yeah yeah and I'm not doing that
Nightmare and by the way when it hits
zero we at zero it's not like with oh I
push it when that when oh yeah yeah my
mama taught me that when that thing
turns yellow oh [__] at least 50 more
miles man well Toyota Camry a 97 Toyota
Camry with that thing it's yellow you're
like [__] please my wife was like we
need gas we need gas I go I look I go
what do you mean it was like just below
a quarter there's two type of people in
this world that'll keep me forever yeah
there's two type of people in this world
the people where it gets past the
halfway mark like we better fill up and
then there's the Risk Takers like your
boy here yep where that thing even at
yellow I'm like nah nah pushing it yeah
I pushed it hard my favorite is when I
asked you if you brush
and you brush your teeth at night
and you go excuse me
never and I'm the same way never never
I'm not brushing myself it's enough I
got a brush them in the morning every
now and then uh jump in bed yeah and
I'll go to kiss Joshua like your breath
smells like dick I'm like it does she
goes do you brush your teeth I'll go
yeah she goes no you no you didn't now
you gotta get out of bed same thing
happened to me I use mouthwash well your
breath smells like an open grave and
then she goes then Jordan goes isn't
this nice I'm like I just don't like it
I just I'm not I'm not the guy now in
the morning you have to of course you
have to when you're sleeping there's
something about that I resent about it's
like so I know a guy who um he's got
great skin and we were joking we go you
got great skin he directs best stuff
and uh funniest [__] everything else and
he's a guy plays lacrosse in college I
got great because I got a whole routine
oh and I go I'm gay right hold up and
Rewind
what do you mean he goes I got a whole
thing for my teeth and my my face I have
creams I go it might be an OCD thing
well or it's gay yeah okay always like
oh yeah I suck dick dude
you're like oh then you don't say then
you can't say anything he's got a very
hot girlfriend his girlfriend's a 10.
sure the reason I know my boy isn't gay
is because he's hilarious because we're
in Boston and the even if he is oh yeah
I know but I know now you're trying to
cover ground here's why you know he's
not gay the waiter comes over the
handsome guy and the guy and he goes he
goes is that guy gorgeous or what he
goes and he's like and he's just like me
I go oh you're gay because I'm very gay
I go me too and so we were talking about
how gorgeous we were asking God
questions about a symmetry see Brian
this isn't helping your friend here
because I've NE I joke around yeah like
the with the best of them
but I don't say ever in my life that
guy's gorgeous because that's sincere
right you that's insane you're gay I'll
go oh I'm gay if I see your hands
through I'm like man that dude is not
only are you that no you have hired
personal trainers oh yeah because you
like the way they look and they're men
because you like to Feast your eyes on
them and I know that's a fact what
personal most like there's
and you said and I looked him up and I
went got kids a looker and you said i i
50 of the reason I hire him is because I
enjoy looking I think maybe I think
that's your Gator no it's not that's
never happened with me it has happened
I've only had ugly trainers that's not
true you had a very much he was a small
window I remember you said I I I hope
very much he brightens my dad I've only
had three trainers that's I've never
said hey I've never you yeah I use that
lingo I said I sucked his [__] and you
said that he's my type dude see you're
getting older right dementia a little
bit and that's your that's your producer
of that show right you know like I said
I have nothing to talk about today
now we didn't get to talk about it
because uh Jay Larson was in we you know
you never know if the guy's into the
fight business yeah but uh over the
weekend they announced Jake Paul Nate
Diaz this is my question for you this is
for everybody in the room you inclusion
you know the fight game second best in
here then George and Brian okay be cool
right who has more pressure on them in
this fight Nate Diaz or Jake Paul now
let me paint the picture before you
answer I'll tell you right now let me
paint the picture because I think most
people assume who it is but let me just
argue for both sides for Jake Paul you
lose again this this Journey's probably
over a lot of pressure you lose this
time you're looking for a validation
this is the first
I mean Anderson Silva Legend different
right older yeah isn't that old right
yeah it's not that old now he's at the
tail end of his career but he's still a
badass Nate Diaz is respected by
everybody in the community he is a
representative of mixed martial arts to
the fullest like he's basically like uh
he's a legend now he's this street and
he plays and he plays no games no so the
argument where oh Jake Paul's fights are
fixed or you know these guys are taking
a fall that narrows out the window now
and that argument doesn't work anymore
because his fights are not fixed no of
course not but I'm just saying the
people that you would use that narrative
right when the hit doesn't work they
start to lie so it's the hate didn't
work he got too big made 40 million off
one fight so they're like well they're
fixed right that was the next thing well
these fights are fixed okay well now the
narrative we know that Nate Diaz there's
not amount of money on this Earth that
you could offer any Diaz brother where
they're gonna take a fall it's not in
their DNA they do not play that game if
you ask them for that trust me they get
on glittering out your ass so fast so we
know that's not fake so now for Jake the
pressure's on because now you're
fighting a real one you're fighting a
real one who's not going to play your
antics you go to grab his hat he's gonna
beat you up you go to push him he's
going to beat you up you go to getting
his face at the uh press conference he's
gonna slap you you know what I'm saying
like he's a real dude he's a real he's a
real dude who's like yeah I'm gonna beat
this kid up yeah it's eight rounds
right and he's coming off a loss where
the loss I think showed us that maybe
Jake's not as far as long as we thought
he fought a real boxer we saw he had
only really he only has a right hand
right now with Anderson Silva the whole
narrative was older he looked this the
best Jake's ever looked but it's still
older and still but he did you know get
wobbled and come to you know pop back up
uh Anderson he rocked him but he wanted
decision so we knew Jay or Jake's gas
tank isn't bad like we thought before we
thought maybe it was a little fragile
there we know it's good so there's
pressure on Jake there because you lose
this one you can still beat up the ksi's
of the world he can fight the YouTubers
but as far as fighting legit guys that
window's probably closed yeah a little
bit but now but unless he trains closed
it's closed it's just gone because
people are done with it when you keep
losing like this so there's that
pressure loser goes home
for Nate though
you're you're bona fide UFC first ballot
Hall of Famer you've as legit as it goes
you are a guy's guy you are the street
legend
you do not used to you do not lose to a
YouTuber you lose to him all credit goes
out the window but I think this is kudos
to Jake Nate when I took this fight if
he didn't respect Jake
so it shows even though that I'm sure
the majority of the Nate fan base like
[__] this YouTuber whatever if they're
real Nate fans they would know the Diaz
brothers would not sign on for a fight
unless they respected the guy Nate
respects Connor he respects Leon Edwards
he respects Jake Paul that's kudos to
Jake Paul
but Nate's entire I think his entire
kind of Street Credit tough guy fight
you anywhere anytime that's on the line
I think there's more pressure on Nate to
represent MMA and what he's done with
his legacy then there's for Jake
thoughts my thoughts are do you like the
breakdown I like the breakdown very much
um there there are two reasons I think
the pressure is more on Jake
youth youth
um
and the fact that
um he's the favorite he's bigger he's
the favorite yeah yeah it's that one
it's at 185 yeah and he's in like now
now native
six one everybody's six one and about
190 when I hung out with him he's about
I was taken by how much larger he was
than I thought and you always are I
always am with every guy you've ever
he's he was walking at 191 or something
like that he ain't small he's out of
Camp long out of camp
um I don't know if that's good or like I
don't know when he comes in at 185 I
don't know what that looks like and what
that means like is that is he's probably
not you know he's probably just training
and yeah you don't have to cut weight
right because just naturally if he
increases his cardio cleans up the diet
cardio is always on point so I'm not
worried about it I always but it is when
he's training it yeah yeah if you don't
train for the fight he'll be in trouble
yes 100 Jake's no punch so there's a
reason why Jake's the favorite the the
the the the the Box Nate's never boxed
before that's what I'm saying so now now
Nate spent a lot of time in boxing camps
or boxing gyms and and box guys like he
was in Andre Ward's camp and in Oakland
in fact I also his brother more sure his
brother his brother did more of the
rounds there but yeah but I think that
they actually told him and the brothers
they're like you guys are a little too
tough here on good told his brother
you're Emma told his brother told told
Nick was like you guys taking too much
punishment you're taking too much but
also fighting he's talking about
practice right now talking about
practice only one of his on it in a
major main event with the eyeballs on
there
and I think that um I'm sure Nate spent
a lot of time boxing in his life tons I
don't know
that's what he does yeah I I think first
of all part of the reason people I say
he's got a great chin and doesn't get
knocked out Nate knows how to roll with
shots Nate doesn't take full shots I
disagree Nate gets hit that's got a head
on him no Nate gets hit if you know a
Nate Diaz fight you like Nate Diaz
because he'll make it a fight he gets
hit but he like he does get hit yes the
narrative that he rolls with punches or
or has a good chin cool the reason why
we know he's a good chance because he
gets hit he got Wild by Conor McGregor
he did he got wobbled by Leon Edwards
like every single fight he gets hit but
I'm gonna say this and when look at the
way he bleeds the reason is in my
opinion at least he still takes those
shots a lot of times on the top of his
Cranium he's not taking him on the jaw
he is he knows
I think you're off on that beat I think
through all the years of fighting the
scar tissue so he's going to open up
easier yeah but this narrative the the
Nate's defense isn't great no and that's
why he's the underdog in this fight
because they're assuming that with
Jake's power it's going to land against
snakes I see the pressures on Jake now
Nate's never been knocked out besides a
head kick from Josh Thompson but other
outside that he's been wobbled you know
he's definitely been wobbled you know
the models would all fight Conor
McGregor wobble him before he got choked
that like he's he's been walked out he's
been like practice against boxers who
are who fight at 35 and 45 and there's a
video of it but
um there are guys in competition he's
only been knocked out once by Joshua
boxing is a different distance look Jake
Jake I said when I saw Jake fight Tommy
Fury what I said was I have respect for
boxing people like well well Jake
doesn't look as good as I thought yeah
yeah he's been boxing for about three
years yeah boxing so hard I can't
believe it
and so when you see a guy who's been
trying to do that it's really really
hard to get good at boxing like you're
watching most of us have eyes and we
we're watching kodo and Pacquiao and the
guys at Canelo we watching so when you
watch those guys who spent a lifetime
perfecting those skills and they make it
look easy correct you don't see the
Nuance in it right and now you see Jake
who's only been doing it for three years
and you say he's not that good whoa hold
it hold it for a second for three years
is amazing hey he's amazing for three
years but also for Jake it's for only
doing three years like to me it never
made sense for me to go against boxes
even though Tommy Fury you know kind of
a boxer but at least that's all he knows
coach well coached well it's only
language that he speaks nothing else big
guy yeah tell me for a big strong guy
and young and can take hasn't taken a
lot of damage so you saw that he was
able to weather those shots and stuff
Nate is at the tail end of his fighting
career period how old is Nate probably
40 almost now I think 37. okay he's 37
30. that's that's
nobody tougher I mean you know he and
his brother are just Warriors to the
core
um but again Bobby you're talking about
a 26 year old against a very weathered
38 year old with nothing to prove
he's he's going to make a lot of money
he has to prove a lot here I think it's
the ma community's on his back this is
boxing and I keep saying it's a fight
though you know you say they say this is
practice this is boxing this is boxing
this is boxing so you got another MMA
fighter at 38 years old stepping in
after a storied and glorified career a
gloried career and a warrior in it with
with a 26 year old who hits super hard
young bigger stronger and uh so I think
the pressure is way more on Jake
but if he has all just because he's
you're expecting him to win
excuse me I'm a betting man I saw those
odds I'm like oh I put money on date on
those odds yeah eight rounds too yeah
Nate Nate's cardio second to nine after
eight rounds it's like all right it
would benefit Nate if it was 12 rounds
eight rounds benefits Jake he his his
um defense might be different in boxing
I if he's coming at you like this and
and
up and taking shots and responding you
know so let me get this straight so a
guy who's had over 40 fights you think
his defense is gonna change after 40
fights against Jake Paul
I think when it comes to boxing he and
that that mid distance I think his hands
are going to be up and it's not going to
be down not chance right no no no no you
think he's going to stand there and
fight exactly the way he fights
well that's a problem
that's why he's an honor dog Brian it's
a prop because I I you know his hands
are uh
are down
right
let me can I see him here I'm trying to
see if there's anything let me see let
me see okay let me yeah let me see Nate
hitting pads
we're not going to show this obviously
on here yeah but let me just see
something let's take a little break I
noticed you got some uh oh yeah nuts
dude I'm not
and you are
you aren't dude do I look rich because
you would think I'm rich because I have
Macadamia anybody holding back yeah
anybody holding macadamia nuts you know
it's like private jet it's it's Ferrari
macadamia nuts in fact on Macadam on
Jeff bezos's uh jet I'm sure you can
find macadamia nuts oh dude it's all he
eats but where do you get the money to
be spending this well this is crazy dude
I'm talking about House of macadamias
dude yeah they're ridiculous lowest carb
first of all the lowest carb nut 33 less
than almonds 50 less than cashews I
don't even need cashews or almonds
anymore out of my house get them out of
my house they had the best fat profile
of any nut like avocado on steroids okay
they have more monosaturated fat don't
even know what that means but it sounds
awesome uh it's also known it's
basically the ultra healthy
Mediterranean diet it's the fat that
like um it's like olive oil but it has
more than Olive Oil okay they are rich
in rare omega-7 fatty acids did you know
about that I'm just doing what every
listeners right now no they're delicious
man they're absolutely delicious and
they're not just for the rich anymore
because also Macadamia has made it easy
for you guys to get your little greasy
paws on these things and while you're
doing it again no no added sugar why do
you say they have greasy Paws and kind
of just how it goes if you're if you
have greasy if you have regular hands
like mine you go with this no add sugar
my favorite of the raspberry white
chocolate flavor we're obsessed with
these nuts covered in these chocolate
look they've vertically integrated with
over 90 Farmers they've cornered the
market to make the highest quality
macadamia nuts in the world okay it's a
bunch of South African Farmers bringing
this incredible super food to you at
prices and in formats you will love yeah
I don't care I get excited but here's
the thing usually they never give
discounts on the macadamia nut not never
but they are now house house of
macadamias has a very special offer for
the fine kid listeners and viewers you
get 20 off your order for a limited time
plus they're giving you guys a free
bottle of cold press extra virgin heavy
on the Virgin Macadamia Oil worth 20
buckaroos when you visit House of
macadamias.com
t-f-a-k damn that's House of
t-f-a-k that's 20 off your entire order
plus a bottle of cold pressed extra
virgin Max Academia oil and with that
with your hair you could run it through
your hair cover your body in it yeah
dude all kinds of things some nuts
macadamias you want the best supplements
in planet Earth huh do you want
something for your brain for your sleep
for your digestive health do you want
daily support you want essential
nutrients you want performance you want
stuff for immune Health on it has got
you and if you're scared to try Alpha
Brain don't because you have the regular
Alpha Brain which if you don't love it
they give your money back no return
necessary but then also they have Alpha
Brain instant Alpha Brain Black Label
which your boy uses Alpha Brain Focus
shot they got every way possible to get
you the best nootropic on the plant
there's still over a million dollars
sorry a million bottles sold over a
million bottles Brian more than a
million dollars Brennan more than a
million dollars oh yeah I really
understood it but I guess a million
people are wrong
yeah dude
okay whatever you're looking for a
protein powders creatine glutamine they
got to help you with your gut health
which is very important especially you
have psoriasis they also got Fitness
streaming Fitness on demand Fitness no
reason you have to go to the gym anymore
on it in 30 minutes well they're
freaking kettlebells best workouts more
than Mobility moving Groove kettlebells
Primal Bell steel Club bases quad bases
yoga mats sandbags we got it all go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k for 10 off your entire order
that's including the Alpha Brain Black
Label you're welcome
I don't know anyone who hits pads with
their hands up like this
yeah but his his hands are down and
they're gonna see that and if he comes
in at that I can show you Canelo hitting
pads with his hands down he's the best
to do it you're not going to learn a lot
from guy hitting pads yeah that doesn't
matter
but you know Nate gets hit like the
argument Nate doesn't get hit he can't
get hit like from Jake Paul for eight
rounds you can't take that right hand
I mean hey Leon Edwards best shot he did
land on Ian Edwards the argument there
is if the fight was 10 more seconds he
could have finished them yeah you know
but he's admiring his work so yeah 26
year old with a lot of power
and he's got that right hand but that
but here's my thing that's all he has
that's it
we saw in the Tommy Fury fight he's like
that as far as the the tools and now
it's a damn good right hand but outside
that you know in his setups he has about
two or three setups that's like that
that's true like there's he's not a
Swiss army knife yeah he can get there
but you know he's a he's a one-trick
pony right now
look at Deontay Wilder but the thing is
people have to also realize when you say
he can get there
you know to get there you have to spar
and to get there you have to take some
damage and take it there you got to step
in that ring all the time and fight real
guys and you know I wonder Jake will
have to ask himself a question how much
of this juice is worth the squeeze like
to get good at boxing you know you've
got to get in the ring and take shots to
the head and there's no other way to do
it like at the end of the day yeah but
uh yeah that's that's why I think the
pressure's on Nate because for Jake
let's say he gets knocked out whatever
in the third round and people like he's
a meme people making fun of him like we
told you it's gonna happen right and all
the haters are celebrating jacking each
other off with you know with your
producer so it's like if he does that
call back so but if he does that for
foreign
okay cool I'm gonna go back to my
YouTube channel make 30 million a year
yeah I'm gonna go sell whatever drink
I'm thinking he quits if he loses to
Jake
you don't have many options and for for
Nate I think the pressure's on because
if you lose to Jake the Connor fight's
gone you don't want to see another Tommy
Fury fight
what do you mean you don't want to see
Jake fight Tommy Fury absolutely not you
know I don't same same replay no yeah
not soon like not in the next year now
in three years if Tommy goes on a run
Jake goes on a run Jake beats him and he
fights Khan sure I'm in is there right
now if you'd like to see Jake fight or
you're you need to see this fight to see
if if it's the same but but again I
think the pressure's on Nate because
that makes sense Nate doesn't have
enough what other avenues is Nate gonna
do so it's like if he loses Jake Connor
fights out the window UFC's not signing
Jake after this I think we're what
happens if I had a crystal ball Nate
wins his fight signs a one fight deal
with UFC gets does the trilogy with
Connor Connor's gonna fight one before
and then however that goes doesn't
matter because the trilogy fight of him
and Nate is always there so I would be
willing to bet during his conversation
with the UFC went I'm gonna dip out I'm
gonna fight this dude I'm gonna beat him
then I'll come back and fight Connor and
I'm out so you're making whatever is 20
million 40 million I'm out right up in
the sunset yep that's all predicate on
him beating Jake if you lose to Jake UFC
ain't signing you you know the fan base
like oh can you believe it this YouTuber
even no one give them credit this
YouTuber beat Nate Diaz Diaz bro lost a
YouTuber
for Jake it's yeah I'm a YouTuber
like when when Logan's fighting Floyd
Mayweather go in there tells me nervous
[__] he goes I've already won dude I'm a
YouTuber fighting Floyd for Jake he
didn't lean into that now yeah yeah I'm
a YouTuber
just be hey hey uh UFC that this is your
BMF
I speed up your BMF what's up yeah so
for Jake it opens up a lot more windows
but also where's Casey loses who I'm a
YouTuber he can always lean into you
guys told me I was a YouTuber yeah yeah
yeah you're right I'm gonna make 40
million you can also say this hey okay
so so give me a hand if I'm Jake watch
this you're a YouTuber you're not a real
boss I thought Nate Diaz yeah I fought
Tommy Fury that doesn't matter I thought
everybody I fought Nate Diaz it's still
it's not you get in the rain and
fighting ideas oh you you want to talk
you want to get in the ring and fight
that guy you want to box him I've been
boxing with three you know the internet
doesn't work like that that stuff
doesn't matter people who who criticize
him are are are should look in the
mirror and take a look at themselves of
course because we're normal people and
we don't make a living off you know
writing YouTube
yeah but that's what they do they're
always going to do that so for Jake I
would lean either I lose yeah YouTuber
what do you want me to do I'm out I'm
gonna go make money over here and he has
it's not like the revenue closes up if
he stops boxing he's still making money
doing his shows doing YouTube Tick Tock
what do you think for Nate though Nate
is a fighter through and through where
do you put this is it where do you put
your money
uh right you know and uh you know Nate's
not five years ago it's not my boy
Jake's my boy five years ago where do
you put your money five years ago before
Jake was boxing no I'm saying Jake all
things that makes sense you said three
years ago Jake is boxing now at his
level
put Nate in a time machine make him 32.
Nate Nate yeah even now Nate the odds
are you know Vegas does those odds to
get money to get traction but I just I
find it hard to believe with Nate's
volume is the level that he's competed
at his boxing experience being in big
fights knowing what's on the line here
no one if he does win this fight you
come back to the UFC fight Conor in a
mega fight there's just so much for him
to lose the pressure to me is on Nate
you think Nate can break down Jake's
patterns and capitalize as he is yes
higher level higher level boxer higher
level IQ too yeah when it comes to the
fight game yeah the business game
different animal
but again Jake just needs Land one so
there's something but again Jake needs
Land one and if he does again the only
guy to ever knock Nate out is a man
named Josh Thompson our boy with a kick
outside that Nate's taking some big
punches and get dingo down to you you
know messed up 100 so you're gonna Bank
on Jake again 25 minutes again your bank
on Jake as you guys call him a YouTuber
knocking out Nate Diaz when the likes of
Conor McGregor couldn't Leon Edwards
couldn't Jorge miles couldn't
that's a weird bat was a tko2 not even
like a straight up yeah it wasn't like
Flatline KO but it's considered a not
technical
knockouts on his records you didn't like
but I'm just saying like Nate's taking
the best of them they fought
was it Leon yeah
or no it was Tony first no it was Tony
Ferguson he almost knocked Leon out he
wobbled Leon yeah now that but that
that's the thing is like if this goes to
the decision it's made all day if if
it's gonna be a stoppage it's gonna be
Jake right so if it goes decision it's
Nate all day but again you're you're
think about the what you're betting on
your bet if it goes under eight rounds
that means Jake gets a finish that means
you're bet on a guy who couldn't touch
Tommy Fury really and it's Gonna Knock
Out a guy who's never been knocked out
by a punch in his entire career you're
assuming as you guys call him not me
this YouTuber is gonna be able to
execute the right combination and
capitalize on knocking out Nate Diaz
that's what you're betting on at minus
200. and I remember this fight like
yesterday in 2011. yeah it was in Denver
that was 12 years ago was that in Denver
12 [__] years ago Las Vegas five of
the night remember that yeah like it was
yesterday
wow
damn
he's fought them all
do you guys think after Jake's uh loss
that he has a little bit more freedom
when he fights like he's more willing to
throw [__] at that always happens yeah
yeah it always happened because he he's
trying to walk this perfect line and
can't get hit and can't lose and once
that monkey's off your back he's like
that's the worst that's it you saw him
literally the next day after his loss
he's giving away free food or whatever
he's like you know I'm boxing he's like
wrapping up boxes giving free food out
so he handled it well because he has so
many options he doesn't have to do this
Nate has to do this he has to do it has
to in order for Nate to keep I don't
know how he is with his money he should
be set with those counter fights and the
last fight we got paid but I would
assume that Nate needs to do this in
order to get this even comparable money
in a year what Jake makes off YouTube
just take this fight there's no other
options for Nate to me you're gonna bat
on the guy with a hundred options and is
grow wakes up in Gucci
pajamas or he bound on the guy who has
one this is his only way to put food on
the table even have kids but you don't
get a reference you know what I'm saying
for me as a fighter and then it's also I
was one of the first guys where it's
like I felt it was like UFC MMA alumni
verse you know these YouTuber boxers
I haven't felt that way in a long time
this fight I feel that way because Nate
Diaz and I don't even really [__] with
Nate Diaz why did he take from 2016 to
2019 off contract dispute didn't feel
like they're getting the money oh a
liquid no not good for me to make any
money but he didn't take as much damage
that doesn't matter man he's a fighter
he don't give a [__] but then also with
the thing about his brother getting
suspended
they just fight and that's why they're
one of their families so big because you
know this morning but it's like when you
get [__] over the true fans rally for
you they never let you know they keep
rattling for you [__] yeah so amazing
but that fight is so interesting
did I sell you I can't wait did I sell
you yeah I don't make a dime off them I
can't wait
are you up
are you beating me money yeah with the
Izzy fight
you know and you know Alex Perez jumped
in like heavyweight and they're they're
Dana came out and said this the other
day he's like he's not getting a title
shot everyone's calling you know Jamal
Hill wants to fight Piera he has to
prove that he belongs at 205 so I'm
giving somebody else through yawn and
people like that first uh I don't know
John wants the fight but Janos wants to
fight with Izzy at 85 but I think you
know you could you could do a yawn I
think you do it I think the perfect
fight to make and then you know would be
Johnny Walker phenomenal fight you think
so now even outside Jamal Hill but the
Yuri the Yuri fight we want to talk
about two dudes that were born
Gladiators boom boom
Strikers but Yuri's like ridiculous
unconventional unconventional karate
Striker I I heard this coach in the
interview I forget they said uh X Pierre
even when he's fighting 85 walked around
at 2 30. oh yeah 2 30. how about that by
the way how about 2 30. now uh you've
been around
so big when he was like I make 85 I'm
like the [__] you are come on dude this
is a giant polish guy like if I'm busy
I'm like go ahead and make it yeah I'll
fight you 85 he's gonna be so depleted
you'd light him up oh my God
uh yeah Yuri he's just in insane [__]
not out to fat he looks just like a
trainer like super thin is he thin
though is it thin to Brennan Schaub or
is he offend everybody so what do you
think he weighs on the off season ah
220. okay so so he's legit this what
does he say 215 maybe 215 63 yeah tall
guy 215 and slender slender yeah big
legs doesn't he have big nose no nothing
nothing was massive on him at all oh
maybe a big day I don't know well he's
he's is he isn't he Serbian or where is
he from no he's not Serbian he's uh he's
from the Balkans they all have huge
dongs I forget where the Greeks and the
Balkans he does check oh huge dongs huge
known to have impossible dicks at least
in my fantasy I mean in my in my
research so 205 I bet you he's walking
at two not two thirty above no not just
really no not chance but up all kinds of
shredded yeah not I mean he just lives
that Warrior life him vs Oxford neither
one of them talks all that [__] they're
just straight up Savages yeah it should
be called UFC whatever is 300 it should
be on UFC 300 and have the 300 Spartan
poster and have both of them on there
that's a great they have like the red
dude you're welcome that's a great call
because they are they're both it's like
two worlds colliding the best of both
just like the best of the Amazon
Gladiators going at it I guess exactly
who we want to see yeah Alex Pierre just
cutting people's heads off in Brazil
might be taller though Pierre is taller
five or so yeah it's huge
2 30 and that excuse me sir he's 2 30
walking around 2 30 when he's cutting to
85. it's so stupid I mean then again
Luke Rockwell's 220 all the time more
than that when he's walking around
before he trains got down to 185 6'4
with his shoes off 6'4 is people throw
height around
6'4 with your shoes off is so rare what
would you say Izzy is you stood next to
him six four six four not six five no
it's four
we have similar height
John's bigger than six four I feel like
but
I feel like Izzy is taller Izzy is
taller than
um
not Alex I mean I'm sorry Alex is taller
than Izzy yes so he might be six five
yeah he's probably six five yeah 240. um
now our boy Gustafson gust is in six six
yeah without shoes thank you so big
thank you so spartum oh man so big six
so big long arms uh in this Prime dude
nightmare oh my God he was [__] good
he never liked fighting apparently or he
just had no he did he was just at the
end of it I think he just got his heart
broken he's good he had the skill to be
world champion just there's DC and Jon
Jones hanging around and remember his
fight was Jon Jones with the greatest of
all time remember he got headbutt by
Anthony Johnson and that kind of yeah I
[__] him yeah and that was for title
wants a rematch it says three years ago
but 178 oh withdrawal that's one this is
three days ago yeah it's just three
years ago but it says 170 what's wrong
yeah because he's his fight he's
supposed to have a fight and then the
guy dropped out
but yeah I love fighting
I absolutely love uh Alexander guests
yeah
huh and did when's that fight going down
between uh Nate and uh Jake Paul August
5th okay we got some time August five
okay let me announce this in the press
conference okay practice get our hands
up we had a hot second we'll definitely
be doing a companion for that that
fight's so fun and this weekend you got
Ryan Garcia Javonte Davis my dick's
foaming I can't wait for that boom
in Portland sold out show that doesn't
matter the thing is you're gonna miss it
what time will that be hey doesn't
matter
[Music]
so if you have a 10 o'clock show and
it's boxing I wonder if they'd stall it
for me
Davis who do you got on that that's a
tough one Javonte though you got smart
money shavonte the money should be on
javonta I'm rooting for Ryan Garcia I
think you can do it this is what's
alarming is when you see and that's what
I said on the shop show is you see
Javonte or jovant yeah you see Javonte
Davis asked for so many stipulations the
contract that's what the holdup was and
and Ryan just goes yeah cool yeah cool
yeah gave up everything I'm like why are
you so confident that's alarming and his
team's like yeah cool we'll do it I'm
like do they know it's alarming for
Javonte that he went yeah cool go yeah
let's do something we don't know because
and they there's a stipulation that he
can't rehydrate he can only rehydrate a
certain weight and the thing goes no
problem what else you want yeah but if
you beat us on the here on the con yeah
cool whatever you want no argument nah
we're good we think we're gonna win like
oh damn but we also want this around
steam goes yeah cool take it
when I hear that and I know boxing I'm
like oh [__] what did they know that's
what's scary to me like because Ryan
being an undefeated fighter put up his
undefeated record against Javonte Davis
makes all the sense in the world but
he's fought he's fought very few times
hasn't he Ryan no he's exactly where he
should be no he is like over 20 fights
right yeah
does he yes
look at wait go back let me see I think
Ryan's like 20 4-0
undefeated [__]
Oscar Oscar did he have I think he has
his he had his abs painted on no stop
you there
he has everything
name something that somebody would do
he's the guy and
what this bothers me because I grew up
such a big Golden Boy fan I love
Australia best of all time the best
dude it's undefeated when they post the
videos of him in the fishnet style I
don't mind that though even then I went
and they had high heels on it I'm good
but why did she make him put the gloves
on silly goose no you probably put it on
you dude he's probably rock hard and
she's like no hold on Daddy hold on put
the fish nuts on he's like all right
[__] let me get this shot he's gonna
hold on Daddy put the high heels on he's
like are they my size she's like they're
big enough he's like [__] it all right
suck my dick she's like hold on hold on
he's oh God what do you want put the
gloves on
but I do know some people that would do
that and the bottom line is if if it's a
good enough time why is Brandon have 15
hard-boiled eggs on his mouth hey [__]
them all gotta eat all the eggs give me
the second one uh yep we'll do well
because if if the party that didn't
deter me from being Oscar fan it's just
the whole then him talking [__] to Dana
it's like only I do that so it's like
you're talking [__] the Dana the cocaine
you've seen the video of him with Canelo
he's all yeah yeah that's on the
backside yeah like what happened yeah
age gracefully like Bernard Hopkins I
think that you see Bernard in the
interviews and he's part of Golden Boy
there's something about Ryan and you
know and he's in a suit and he's the
Gray beard just looking like a pimp you
know I saw yesterday speaking of [__]
Asian beautifully Eric Dickerson
is he looking good dude I'm standing
like talking about well let's just start
for people that don't know who he is
you're talking about a 0.01 percenter as
an athlete right you would have been
obsessed even you know me I don't give a
[__] about he's got Shifty My Age It's
gotta be my how old's Eric Dickerson I
guarantee he's my 62. he's 60 [__]
two okay look 62. looked 40 he looked
40. give me the body give me the body
dude Jack he's got a blowout ass he's
got a tail piece on him still yeah dude
you know that Hall of Fame dick don't
quit dude quit dude
six three oh boy jacked in shape and not
like juicy Jack like in shape I saw
Shannon Shakespeare himself I saw
Shannon I'm not that old no he's just
shoot him up shoot him up oh Eric
dierksen looked [__] good and I was
with Eric Griffin like you know this and
it goes how dare you that's Eric Griffin
man well that's Eric Dickerson I was
like yo you know he's like [__] yeah I
know wow every bit of something good
everybody
11 Seasons yeah you're talking about
you're talking about just a a 0.01
percenter very different dude played at
Southern Methodist yeah I've met
Marshall Faulk and Marshall Faulk tiny
he looks like he I I'm telling you he if
he well now let's bring packages no I
met him when he's playing if he was
delivering packages when UFC he looks
like Brian Simpson yeah yeah um bring up
Brian Simpson the comic yeah they look
very similar but you'd be like the
hashtag no racism you'd never think he
was an athlete like that he looks just
like regular him and Brian Simpson built
looked the exact same yeah
might have been a little bit like
Chappelle Lacey like built like that
dude very similar right by the way
that's a good call that's a crazy call
that's a crazy call right there it's
like boom yeah Brian yeah who knew that
Brian Simpson was that good an athlete
Marshall Faulk was ridiculous
oh ridiculous
athlete a ridiculous what college you
went to no San Diego State wow
you saw Eric Dickerson yeah Shannon
sharp same thing he was just I sucked
them off like I was like well you could
just suit up right
dude stupid
Jack that's like uh Sean uh Josh pray
has a whole thing on him hilarious
um
wait swung up oh that was uh
at a press conference a while ago right
yeah
now most people are are picking tank
because his his IQ inside the range and
we've seen right we've never but this
the whole caveat here we've never seen
uh tank get hit
Ryan's gonna hit him so it's like candy
knockout tank nobody's been here
trevante isn't that much shorter than
Ryan oh javonte's so small is he wearing
boots yes he has like platforms on okay
he's so small I had an interview with
him I was a girl Jesus Christ I don't
respect people this small
but it was fun
yeah Ryan has the speed but yeah it's
dicey with tank huh I can't wait for
that fight can't wait
look at that Ryan's a fighter man it's
gonna be good Ryan's a fighter man hell
yeah dude there was a like a either a
live Instagram from I think gervante's
feed and they called Ryan Garcia and he
said let's bet our purses and Ryan
didn't even finish like yeah let's do it
then the way that Javonte react is like
you want to do it yeah let's do it
that's what's alarming is Ryan and his
team are just like what do they know we
don't yeah
all the stipulations contract and that's
what that's what ruined the Tommy Fury
fight against USIC the stipulation
contract fear he's like [__] no because
it's a tough fight you know and the the
stipulations were in the rematch and
they wanted 70 and all this stuff and
Fury's like nah [__] no because he knows
there's a he's such a good fight there's
a chance he can lose Tyson Fury yeah
Tyson Pacific no not a chance
Ryan was like yeah go do it yeah
what do they know we don't interesting
not weird
is it a mind [__] is it no that's that's
business because remember he has the
entire team behind him that has to sign
off on it even they're like yeah cool no
problem all of them is Oscar De La Hoya
in he's he Ryan Garcia's in Golden Boy
camp right I don't think he is anymore
he used to train with uh canelo's Team
how about this well he's also training
with Andy Ruiz no no no no no no no Andy
Ruiz trains at canelo's yeah but Ryan
Garcia used to be with uh they had a
falling out with Canal scene you know
why they're falling out no canelo's uh
head coach was so busy he's like I just
don't have time for the kid
excuse me sir he's like we're good and
so Ryan left when did his own thing
lives up the street now lives right up
there
right there interesting right there so
who is he he's under Golden Boy he's got
he's got great coaching he's the best
coaching you can get who I would imagine
Ryan Garcia he's still on a camp with
the best coach I'm trying to see him in
no but they all got good coaching at
that level all of them tank has a good
team you know tanks team yeah yeah isn't
he out of it isn't he out of the
employment Camp he's not no no no that's
old dude didn't did teach him stuff
no he was way he was good before that
that's why Floyd took him under his wing
they'll get at that level everyone has
good coaches man it's not even about
that no one's training with her [__]
you know random ass coach
wow look at that Calvin Ford
my son had his first day of Jiu Jitsu
and loved it in Santa Monica yeah good
gym made me feel so good yeah at uh
Kenny Florence it's not it's not but
it's close to that and my son just had a
they all the kids took care of me but
I've been training my son I've been
making him work out with me and I make
him box so it was so good for him
because when they were doing all the
exercises and stuff wasn't a big
familiar to him yeah it was that foreign
I kept saying that to my ex I was like
just let me do this to him so I can get
him used to this yes if he likes it he
loved it he liked it that's good he
loved it the kids were great you know
it's like great most of them should be
yeah some should be in there it's just
really cool man he's going how many
times a week he wants to go three times
a week that's a lot for a kid but no no
I mean I think it's standard my son's
seven goes four times a week he does yes
yeah well he has other sports he does
track and swimming and all that so it's
tiger yeah three's not bad yeah two two
minimum if you're going once a week if
you're going once a week don't do it no
I agree with you no if you do once a
week and it's like I think every year
that's me but every day if that if
that's what he's passing his track right
yeah
white so let's not do that because
that's you know where that leads right
or do I need to educate you right now
he's also he's also got
Daddy's all right
he's not gonna win any sprinting matches
though no no so track let's ditch that
right unless it's long I'd say we don't
want to be a long distance Runner
because that sucks it's a long distance
cool no it sucks but but
it sucks but if you like to run it's
great I know but as a sport it sucks
because I don't want to watch it and
there's no girls you can run a mile fast
uh you know you can run 10 miles but
just show your son a video of the
Ethiopians running the long cross
country you're not from Canada or
Ethiopia right so we're not going to be
down competing 100 meter you will that's
not happening let me show you the
Olympic let me just show you well his
coaches are it looks awesome the Trump
rally our black gentlemen who happen to
be Olympians
and they're like well let's run the
track you know what this comes down to
I'd see your son finish nope I'd see
your son and I go you have fun
even though you're coming in dead last
you have fun my son is going to be doing
Jiu-Jitsu in a sport I believe in
getting into the sport that makes you
feel good about yourself yeah I get some
wins under your belt get some wins under
your belt because you need a certain
level in that track game you know now my
boy's tall where is it where did Bill
and Greg go my boys oh Bill and Greg hit
the books yeah yeah well my boys got
long arms long legs a tail piece on them
and broad shoulders he's athletic he can
he picks up on stuff real quick very
very uh coordinated so Jiu Jitsu might
be okay for him I'm I'm optimistic about
that but uh box is very well can turn
his body it's really great all that
coordination is good yeah you have fun
right because yeah
I might get too but you're a kid
different comes from a difference
I don't want to do this man
it's different you're putting your kid
against my kid right now this is not
this is your life dude he's seven you're
out of line you know what is he he's
seven but who is he rolling with in Jiu
Jitsu bigger kids but oh I'll put up my
three-year-old right
how old is your kid you're seven wait
are you telling tiger for you
right
I didn't want to do this broadcast
you saying tiger is taking down 11 year
olds I'll tell boss start hydrating
right now okay you're being
disrespectful right now bro
oh bottom line is did you have I have
some Intel on your son though I
understand your son's getting pitted
against some bigger kids older kids you
can't go with kids age can't go for 10
or under can't go through is that true
we've had to change the schedule is that
true doing different days yeah
it's good and bad you know because he
goes with older kids finally he's losing
and he doesn't like that because he grew
up just dominating so it's like this is
how this goes dude but then also
you know it's okay you'll be the best of
jujitsu
do you have fun
because I'm gonna make money well let's
just go unless you're Gordon Ryan it is
kind of weird to be cursed with the kind
of body that excels in sport because
because now you're in that category in
that Arena you're labeled that yeah
that's what I was it's also super hard
to make it it's actually super hard to
make it in sports too and I'm not
worried about that with if he has
athletic ability say yeah run with it
you have no idea what door is going to
open or what's going to lead you to the
connections you make I'm playing T1 ball
is great because it opens a bunch of
connections yeah if you get you in
college space for your college hell yeah
dude run with it yeah I mean if you know
if he gets to a point where he looks
like he could play pro
I mean
who knows there's so many factors going
to that is he like baseball does he like
like yeah he likes baseball what's his
favorite Oscar football all day yeah all
day sorry or he wants to be a NFL player
all day yeah and he's built for it yep
there's Brothers you'll be in him so I'm
like get ready dude give your brother
another viewers the boys might be the
world needs football players and your
boys have that Bond structure CT is a
little fun I tell them all the time CT
ain't bad look at your dad it's not bad
CT ain't bad so so Boston is is is
already showing signs of being more
robust oh yeah really giant dude it's
got some handstands and then just
aggressive Uber aggressive like you're a
problem dude yeah
my friends this I'll put it this way
we're not confused on his pronouns you
feel me I do you feel me it's all boy
you feel me oh boy he's not a baby
no like if I came in he had a dress on
it would literally blow I I would assume
the Earth is flat before I see that can
address well I'm gonna say something and
and my wife will get mad at me
I'm obsessed with my son my 15 month old
I'm obsessed with all my kids but my son
he's such a blast when my son sees
bright shiny sequin things
and if you want to get his attention
show them a pair of high heels with
sequins on him and he goes so he might
be a Gaby I might have a Gaby and I'm
gonna love him just the same yeah I'm
accepting it's fine
damn right treat him different right
right
extremely a little different you're out
of line sir I'm just saying we're not
going to the football game right I'm
like yeah I'll go take you see the new
excuse me there are plenty of games
there are plenty of gay men that love
football I'll just put on uh you know
some [__] have you have you met gay
guys Queen yeah on YouTube
like we're doing different things right
there are definitely gay men that watch
well I can get burgers and go to a
football game
we're gonna get some strawberry shakes
and watch Queen on YouTube we had super
stereotypical no that's a good afternoon
Uncle brand comes over strawberry with
two ice cold strawberry shakes and
something Queen perhaps first of all and
some eyeliner
hey my son might be the kind of gay guy
who's like a bad guy yeah you know what
I mean and yeah you know what I mean
don't talk to him that way yeah I told
you that's my joke but it's true about
my buddy Keith who goes I go do you his
boyfriend was this really hot hot Asian
guy beautiful body with a bubble ass and
I swear to God myself
no because he's uh Filipino all the
Filipino you have big legs Caked Up
Caked Up back on them uh uh had a little
earring on his ear just gorgeous sure
and um worse hair over one eye
um and my boy who wrestled in college
wrestled in college makes millions of
dollars sure thanks guys only likes
Asian dudes said we're standing there
and he goes look at his ass
you know he goes he goes you know why I
put up with all his [__] and I go
why and he goes look at that ass oh
my man I go my man I did I go wrong man
I get it I feel sick to my stomach my
man we're speaking the same language
my man speaking the same language you
just throw up right now no no no no
that's cool man listen you talk a big
game that guy talks that guy talks hard
if he gives himself the Derma mulraney
or whatever that guy's name is I'm using
I'm using a code name and and you're
drunk and you got some you got some some
stimulants in you you got some I don't
know if it's cocaine no my wiener won't
work on that ketamine no it won't work
on anything it's just not my life would
be easier if I was gay it just won't do
it for me yeah it's a bummer no air in
space no but I said to my boy I go do
you ever do you ever get taken by
hitting a turn and he goes he's selfish
he goes what are you talking about and I
go do you ever I mean I don't know on
holidays yeah he goes hey I don't do
that [__]
I was like you're a gay homophobe I was
like I'm asking a question that's a true
story yeah you just he's like nah man
what are you gay I'm super confused
right now man that's great because your
little twinker has a root yep right yep
still a root hairless root but it's
there it's a root like an eggplant yeah
no hair apparently he's he's got an
Italian Brazil on him what's that mean
Brazil is a sausage bring up Brazil you
could say cannoli b-r-a hey hey hold on
hey I'm a champion what's the problem
how do you spell Persian r-a-z well you
you know you can make it easy for him
say canola it has a big cannoli on him
right cannoli that's such a detailed
reference
which one looks like a wiener
uh
yeah you see that when before you cut it
it's thick it's thick it's a thick
rolled uh piece of meat there you go
yeah that's Italian that's stuffed meat
that's a challenge
put all the cheese and spices they put
it all the Italians oh that looks nice
oh it's delicious
it's something else man you don't see a
lot of those no but you do you're
Italian you know what the problem is
though with that it's gonna be a dry
meat because the oven's gonna be dry not
if you do it right you can do medium
rare on that no see how much fatty fat
areas that's where you got a fatty fatty
cut
you do it right with tomato sauce forget
it something else you could have said
the guy has a cannoli on though you know
so the recipe no it's thinners Brazil's
thick no you're the right spot you get
along cannoli it's not car station
[Music]
dude I'm 56 but for real I'm 40. I got
it you can get along but I'm referencing
to a penis I don't want to talk about
this stuff I want to talk about
important things but this is important
this is important I just feel like the
cannoli reference is better yeah look at
that why that's like 11 12 years ago I
was like let's do a podcast
still talking about cannoli for wieners
we've never not talked about dicks I
mean literally in this podcast we didn't
talk about I don't want to do that we
didn't talk about wieners uh with Jay
Larson I was proud of us yeah all right
I think we did talk about wieners at one
point I think we did I really do think
we did I think I turned him off with the
Boston Bomber I want to see I don't want
to see I want to see if we can avoid it
hold on what is this oh my God so let me
fill Brian in so love is blind star
Jackie says Netflix won't allow her and
boyfriend Josh to attend the reunion due
to death threats what this is how I'm
saying the show's massive right and
there was a knock because in the reunion
they were Netflix and do it live there
were so many people trying to watch that
the servers break down it's that popular
well think about this Chris Rock did his
live zero problems
Love Is Blindness damn let me fill in
girl on the right Jackie dime right
she's the prettiest girl on the show
yeah she originally gets with this guy
um it starts with the m I have a really
nice black Marshall yes
Will Smith uh
that guy would be a version of Will
Smith In Love loves blind really did
this season where they did a lot of beta
like soft males and women run the show
it's all on purpose right yeah so this
guy's Super Beta he gets with a lady
from the streets he did and she while
they make a connection what they make a
connection from the streets I'll tell
you let me tell you all right they make
a connection they finally see each other
he proposes she's like okay and she
tells them she's like usually my type
you know that's why I did the show
because I you know I can't have a long
time right she had six minimum six five
full sleeve tattoos on them okay and
then she goes uh you know you just not
my type but that's why I'm doing the
show clearly it doesn't work out and
then finally she goes to break up with
him and she goes well before she's about
to break up when they're about to go
back to Seattle where the show's being
shot of this time it was Chicago now
it's Seattle
she's nervous he goes what's wrong with
she goes I'm just I'm I don't go back to
my old ways my old thought ways because
I'm gonna get my phone and so many guys
text me I don't he's like you're past
those days she's like yeah yeah you're
right it's like when you see an
alcoholic like no no I'll never you're
not past those days your type is your
type so but then she had a connection
with this other dude who bring him up
chin she has connections with other dude
so in the house right
the the nice guy Marshall the the the
the kind of the [__] of the show right
uh Marshall goes man who's talking my
girl who's lying saying that I make a
connection well he doesn't know the guy
that he is also in love with his girl
wrestle that Ohio State and it was very
successful has way worse cauliflower
than me so he goes He that guy Ohio
State Ohio State super successful
businessman now so he goes back into the
guy's house and he's like who's talking
my girl he goes I am he goes yeah any
before the cat before he saw him in
person he's like you don't want these
problems man I'll go off on them
hey so but he's real he's like real
quiet and like confident
so the guy's like Utah my greeners yeah
I am and then the guy keeps telling us
oh you can just help very calm he goes
I'm not scared of Confrontation and the
guy's like yeah all right that's cool
well so that guy is getting in his face
yeah that guy no it was across the
kitchen
yeah the the soft guy and but that's why
Society right now is hating on the guy
that wrestled Ohio State because he's
like a real dude he wants something he
was like nah man I'm Into You Yeah and
found out they broke up showed up to
whatever their thing was like hey I'm
still in love with you we need to try
this question he was so they were
together before they were they were
together before and she couldn't decide
between the two pick the guy on the left
realize he's super soft if they break in
she's gonna have to defend the house
that's correct and so she went with
homeboy who's a real dude on the right
homeboy a big guy no tiny but still oh
he's not big no he's not big but he was
just like hold up like I'm gonna instead
of putting that guy who I don't know his
feelings over Minds I'm gonna shoot my
shot she ends up liking him because he's
a real dude and so the the again they
didn't buy ears they didn't invite them
to the reunion because they're getting
so much hate because society's like oh
you [__] up nice guy over nice guys
finish last this always happens nah man
hey man no she's a thoroughbred and and
that guy's a stud you don't get you know
how hard it is to be on the wrestling
team how Ohio State I knew you're gonna
harp on that but I know you're gonna
jack off yeah it's whatever you're also
in college but the thing is is it's
attractive whatever he doesn't do it
anymore about the wrestling to be that
kind of guy that's a that's a hyper
masculine man she said she likes
hypermatics that's what she said and so
then people want to give her back lash
because she's like no the soft guy is
not my type this guy's my yes love is
blind but with even being Love is Blind
I still have a type and now people want
to be upset because this guy's taking a
shot
he's got tits on him too why are you
gonna argue with those tits who skips
leg day it's not a big deal shoots
shoots a good double single arm drag you
know what I'm saying someone put chicken
legs nice chicken legs
oh man it says damn baby I love the way
you I love the way you squint when
you're trying to use three brain cells
collectively people are so nasty I can
see why jacquelina cheated on you now
um no his entire page is hate because
you know because again Society wants to
protect the soft guy and this guy
shouldn't be doing this so what should
he do just sit in the wings and in the
shadows and miss out on a girl you made
a connection with yeah what's with these
people
wait
wait damn second in the world
in in gnoki Jiu Jitsu yeah that's
why they hating on the guy because he
went for the girl and she went for him
because everyone loved the guy because
he was like soft no but because he's not
the guys he's a great guy he's a nice
guy but not alpha male she her kids
don't perk up for it correct and besides
like no you should pick that guy that's
what's wrong with sight it's like but
that's not what she likes that's what
you guys want for her she wants this I
got the cauliflower
the majority but online came online they
can hide behind whatever so this guy's
getting all this hate I don't agree with
it like why do you why do you guys give
a [__] if that's her type but love is
blind it's not blind no
it's not I know that's the well no it's
the theme of the show it's not it's not
awesome I love love is blind I think on
the first fourth uh season I watch all
of them none of them work out none of
them work out because as humans we like
what we like we like making emotional
connection at the end of the day if
you're not attractive that's a friend
[__] that's it that's why we have
friends that's it I love your brain you
look like [__] to me what you know what
I'm not attracted the first time I'm
hearing this no you know this you're not
my type dude I shaved my mouth you know
tell me to shave my head and I did it
kind of
guys did you
love is not blind this podcast sucks
love is blind if you want to make
friends I agree love is blind if you
want to make biology is biology
everything else is a lie you can lie
about it and and talk yourself in and
this is a problem with a lot of
relationships you talk yourself into
being with somebody you're not attracted
to but they have a great personality a
great job they look amazing friends your
parents love them that ain't who you're
supposed to marry the person you you
live with is the person you also want to
get naked with and do dirty [__] with
yeah otherwise you're gonna find
somebody to do that with that's right
not your why correct correct and then
you're gonna get judged for that and be
in big trouble so it's the way it is
oh really they don't work out oh why
because they get married after 20 days
and they've only seen each other for 14.
go to the she couldn't go because death
threats
that's how passionate people hey imagine
this dude just imagine this imagine it's
mainly females I'm not I'm like maybe I
might be gay there's not too many men
that want to show it's only females
imagine sending a death threat because
she picked somebody that you thought she
should be with and you just met this
[__] think about how crazy you are
eight days think about your life you
know that all this stuff comes from very
a very small group of people oh
shoplifters uh you read this in New York
City I think uh it's one in three get uh
reprimanded no no but but if you look at
the crazy amount of um oh they've been
doing caught like 177 times some [__]
yeah same people well it's because the
show Lucy goosey on the walls they're
like no it's not their fault they're you
know stealing it you know it's because
society and white privilege it's insane
and so they're like let's let them out
and they just keep doing it they just
keep doing it yeah well that's why uh
Walmart so Walmart closes in a poor
neighborhood so all those people in that
poor neighborhood of color had jobs and
don't have anywhere to shop
so all so so when you have so when these
white liberals and they're white
Liberals are pushing for this uh you
know no incarceration and for all this
all the stuff what happens is those
companies can't be in business there so
all those older ladies all those good
law-abiding citizens of color
neighborhood majority who rely on
Walmart for a thousand they lost it they
lose it we'll think about how many
people how many jobs I provide correct
and so that's what these liberal Soros
Soros funded DA's get wrong you are not
the friend of people of color it drives
me nuts it drives me nuts you better
start educating yourself and oh by the
way if you hate the
vote in the primaries
I never do vote in the primaries one
time one time only really got sent the
death threat to that lady on Love is
Blind
did you get so upset you sent the death
where are my toe holes if I take them
off there's a problem and I'll tell you
why I need tractions they hurt I'm
coming at you oh my toe has never hurt
okay I told it's never heard you never
say that because they look uncomfortable
they're not uncomfortable no they're
just flip-flops on planet Earth yeah
yeah the best flip-flops on planet Earth
they better be I'm obsessed that price
they better be well you get you buy one
for the rest of your life yeah it better
last for the rest of my life yeah yeah
they do what do you got Jen all right
first one is this right here I saw this
earlier I saw this earlier in the week
oh I saw it was this I was trying to
figure out is this high school it's high
school this was gross yeah so it's gross
and I saw so I looked at the original
video the original video so it's a high
school wrestler uh you know with a match
with another High School wrestler and
the guy when I saw the original video
the guy that punched him that sucker
punched him yeah he was losing
everything and so the guy that won
wanted to shake his hand and that's when
he punches yeah
the guy in the blue is the one that lost
pretty much everything
this reminds me of the Aurora Hills
wrestling team days
gymnasium oh look at this yeah this
guy's good nice
you pin them no I think he did a pin him
eventually in the original video but
here's the kid who won little Dime Piece
too boom
this is a douchebag move I think this is
his dad that's running I think he has
dad or coach
just got pissed off
and now the dad goes up there he's like
I'm gonna rip the what's wrong with such
a douchebag move I don't know I don't
like how no adult or anyone there like
did anything no one reprimanded him
nothing but the police were involved
eventually so what are they gonna do
that young kid though uh well the people
everyone's asking for him to be banned
for life which I don't know if that's
the best thing banned for life
I bet you he's got no dad in this house
he's got no father I imagine something
but no excuse you can't that's
fatherless that's fatherless Behavior
well 100 I don't think you suspend a kid
forever for life no I think he can't
wrestle with us this season but sure
yeah he needs canceling you can turn him
into a criminal and ban him from
everything or yeah that's not the answer
I think the answer is he's still he
can't compete but shows up to wrestling
practice so he still has to learn the
discipline and then the next year he can
compete and they're gonna be coming for
him he's gonna he's gonna pay the price
that way
yeah but I I think the team should be
disqualified for placing for state so
there's animosity in that room and that
kid gets his ass whipped in that room uh
that's what I would do I'd penalize the
team because it's team sport don't get
twisted you know actually criminal
Behavior so that's why the police are
involved yeah it becomes a legal matter
um it becomes actually assault real
assault so
uh it's just such parents are both
miners are cooperating
if that's my son dude
it's tough because you know you can just
play and hit them all you want that's
not really the answer it'd be tough if
that was my kid who got hit because I'm
not going to touch the kid but that Dad
oh that Dad you you have all the
problems I don't know what I don't know
what I'm gonna do well I'm breaking his
arm like you don't remember this bubba
yeah yeah it's hard not to hit you're
not gonna be able to ride anymore
every time we go to write something like
I need to think of this Mom you gotta
remember me yeah
tough one I don't know here's another
crazy one so this is at a Southwest
Airlines some dude was pissed off that
there's a baby screaming and crying for
like 45 minutes I'm sure we all have
experienced having a baby as a parent
who's flown with kids on my own two kids
there's nothing you can do exactly so be
cool
dude this guy this is a guy who doesn't
have kids and probably flying to can't
wait to get to Senior Frogs right you
just can't wait to get Margaritas
probably drinking on the plane I'm
already ready to fight right now just
here oh you're gonna hate this guy
it's a three minute video so we can't
play the entire thing but that poor kid
here's the thing [__] stop it this can
make me matching it's gonna bum me up
here's the thing too that guy yelling
like that you realize that's causing the
baby more anxiety and to make the kid
cry even more
[__] you it's causing everyone in the
plan anxiety I would have been like hey
[__] you come come say something come to
my face and let's see oh no I would have
put no I went away from him because of
me I'm like oh the baby's not gonna be
the only one crying this plane that's
right you're [__] up yep yep we can
fight you [__] lose is that old again
so get up and say something uh there's
it's not a guarantee but opinion this is
his wife that looks like even a shitty
version of Honey Bush she's so bummed
out she's just like this holding her
head no it might be having some kind of
a weird that's the dude yeah he might
have his own problems look at her she's
like oh no this is my husband well he's
cross-eyed people
step brother who just didn't make the
team no it looks like Shaq's brother
that grew up at the YMCA and like never
made it yeah and he's so much resentment
against this but also hey
um get that sweater off
um yeah he's he's just a dude I mean who
knows I'm surprised other dads on the
plane because I'm sure there's other
dads hey you know what like all the dads
are just did a dad ass whooping
I remember someone said like uh he was
saying like tell them it's a baby it's
like but you're a man you're a grown man
why the [__] are you making so much
noise because he's like yelling
constantly yeah you know the the baby
crying's not gonna Force this plane to
land early but you're dumb ass well yeah
I would have to assess if the guy is all
there some people I don't care yeah no
we give too much leeway oh mental health
nah [__] you're a terrible person yep
you can get dealt with today yep because
you flew the wrong Spirit Airline just
Daddy's on this and you think I want to
be in here with my two kids flying
direct to [__] Oklahoma City I'm
gonna rip your hat off
yeah so this uh I didn't see this on any
major news outlet but apparently this
Colombian model caught this UFO on a
this is definitely some kind of a drone
okay well I don't know well let's see
I'll show you guys
that's on her private plane
it'll slow down here for a second that's
such a drone
and it's even slowed down even more
I mean that's a drone baby
that's easy or it could be a balloon or
something I don't know well it doesn't
appear to have any ship alerts it's like
a [__] some kind of a some that's a
drone and did you in the last one in the
league classified things there was like
way more drones and balloons that we
were made aware of I've always thought
they were drones just
I mean it's also very alien-ish that we
assume
but did you hear them that's right by
the way she's cool the alien might have
been come to abductor Jesus Christ hey
the aliens are taking her to have sex
Jesus Christ to reproduce what in the
world is going on here sir she's very
thick this I know I'm not gay because
people like hey look at that alien I'm
like don't care hey excuse me what's
your name that's when I know I'm not gay
red and quick alien get your phone out
nah [__] I'm talking to her this girl
makes me forget about all the Jack Black
guys
um Jack Black look at her you said Jack
Black and that's fine I did Jack the
black guys oh jacked black yeah okay
yeah that's her look at her there right
there now that's so mistake but um as
some people say if you can touch them
it's more real than that alien video
it's more real than that you can touch
that she is gorgeous she's cool
did you hear Elon Musk about aliens
he's like listen if anybody knew about
aliens I would trust me I'd be the first
one to tweet that out he goes we don't
know [__] right he doesn't have any
evidence there's zero out there yeah he
was I think he was and I deal with space
I've been in space there's no aliens
here's we have no evidence whatsoever
right he was it would be out there he
was trust me be the most liked tweet of
all time if I knew aliens and I want to
blast that out he's like I've seen no
evidence yeah
there does seem to be a breakthrough in
technology
that's going on in our Pentagon that is
that might be that might change
everything
I was talking about physics
I'm sorry do it again no I was saying we
take the square root of Brennan I'm
trying to get I'm talking this is
science talk no can you talk about new
section can you talk about time like you
do Jay Larson oh man
those tits are not real but they will
now you have my attention bro I'm back
tissue I'm back that's it
yeah she's cool [__] the alien video
what else you got chin uh so I mean
I think you Brandon has been have been
obsessed with p uh Pete Davidson's I
like it he's always been nice to me too
I love this guy so Charlemagne the guy
was in an interview with them and Pete
David Pete Davidson has a new like TV
series coming out called bubkus and then
he asked him about his dick because you
know everyone talks about his dick all
the time so this is how he responded uh
the worst okay uh nothing sitting around
your penis since everybody always
thought about you I don't understand
it's really not that special it's a very
normal sized penis it's like you know
not too big or too small it's just like
you know yeah I don't understand that
it's like baby bear porridge just yeah
it's just like big enough to enjoy and
not big enough for it to hurt okay is
what I was told
if it's a story based on your life so
that's pretty much what he's also doing
is because you don't want the hype man
did you ever you don't you don't want to
deal with that where girls are like he
said oh Ariana Grande said she said big
dick energy but but Ariana Grande he on
his pet in his special he goes this is
not a this is not a dumb person she
broke up with me and decided to [__] it
up for me the rest of my life because
she said he's got a really big dick now
every girl I'm with afterwards is
disappointed that's what he said so he's
just trying to lower your expectation
now he probably got a dick on him but
when they think you know your mind
wanders man we're crazy people all
humans are crazy you know he's like it
like it's like if you were single Brian
someone's like dude you gotta take a go
at that girl she's into YouTube that's
the best sex ever yeah better better
than a porn star dude and then you do it
but in your mind if you have to build up
you're like oh this can be insane now
she might be really good but in your
head it's built up too big they're one
of the most beautiful women I've ever
met in my life I was in college right
after college
and she liked me and my buddy had been
there and he goes like this I'll never
forget she was he's been where I don't
he was had sex with her she was so
beautiful and my buddy goes like this my
buddy goes uh you won't like it
and I go
I won't why what's weird he goes no no
nothing no giant dick what do you mean
no I mean what do you mean no and he
goes I don't know you'll see just
nothing there I was like what are you
talking about she's a 10. maybe she's a
dead fish though don't say any noise I
can't I can't explain why it was but
same thing it was like eating it's like
seeing this incredible meal and it had
no flavor it was like yeah it was like
that it was just there's nothing to it
she was an engineer the way she smelled
there was nothing sexy about it so I've
been a sociopath nothing sexy those
feels dead behind the eyes you're like
hey man yeah maybe yeah nothing why are
you staring at me like I'm giving a
[__] Ted Talk yeah I don't know dicks
in you there was Zero there was Zero
react yeah
yeah that's all that's all Pete's doing
here he's just trying to lower the
expected everyone chill it's not like I
only heard good things about Pete
Davidson from everybody yeah good guy
well he's sweet he comes off as like a
really nice good guy
all right
um real quick one tomorrow Hamlin
apparently His official cause of the
reason why he died at that moment was
something called Cambodia quartus which
is like if there's an impact in on your
heart at a certain time of the beat
that's what we said that's what I said
it's happened in WWE like those certain
impacts just at the wrong time Zach yeah
specific time can you believe they
thought was the vaccine can you believe
that
you believe that so he's cleared the
play now
oh yes I'll take that what no he'll play
he'll play next year that's cool good
for him at least he's okay
did you guys see this in New York City a
parking garage that collapsed now
something happened uh This Is Where It
gets weird man I'd like to call up Sam
tripley we should have a mono conspiracy
chat like bat signal because so they
heard things going off before it
collapsed bombs going on six hours now
did you hear this morning if you read
the news happened in Seattle too similar
things
I don't think he's anti I don't know
what's going on there
so yeah so Witnesses said there was like
hours before there was some banging
noises and but there's not supposed to
be any construction going on and this
place had violations since 2003 but they
never fixed it
um anyways it started collapsing there's
like footage of it on ring cameras God
that's one person died only one yeah one
person no wait that sucks for that one
person I think got only one the parking
garage collapsed yeah in America in
Manhattan I think it's man I want to die
like that that would suck oh I'm the
worst all the time would you rather die
like I'd rather die with the rock
falling on me Malibu
that wasn't me the main collapse but
then you could see the pictures of all
the cars like
sinking into it nothing walls got
destroyed no no imagine no matching of
like your McLaren P1 sin up top there
and you Insurance like oh [__] dude no
thanks like dude there's this there's
this I forget my brother follows him but
there's this guy remember when the
Hurricanes came in Florida people have
cars in Florida this guy I think had a
McLaren P1 they're estimated around to
buy about 3 million so he got caught in
the Hurricanes there's water I think
Naples there's water damage all over it
it was completely engulfed sand got into
the [__] engine all this stuff this
YouTuber goes and buys it he's a car guy
he goes and buys and goes we can salvage
this thing the guy's like yeah enjoy it
man because you get you know there's
only so many insurance is not going to
give you three mil you can't buy another
one right so he salvaged this thing and
he's going it's gonna take you know
probably a year at least to salvage it
but he opens it up there's like seaweed
on the engine there's [__] rust all
over the battery there's one part I
forget where it's at and he's like and
the guy's taking off it's good for
YouTube too you know he's getting his
money back too just about the YouTube
views not 3 million but I forget where
you pay for it maybe 575 mil 1000 575
000 for 3 million dollar car wait just
damage so the guy's like oh this if this
part's dead this guy goes up this part's
damaged me 275 000. they pull it and he
looks rusted he's like [__]
he's again that's going to take forever
to get here from McLaren
but it's a rest but even let's say
575 by the time you restore it you know
it will probably make you know still
probably 700 Grand if someone's gonna
buy it but then it's salvaged parts
right so I don't know if you can sell
for the same price but they're sick it's
a cool project that he's doing damn that
water a lot of content too all right
salt water for a day oh more than that
way more than that yeah way more than a
day and just everything's done oh the
guy had all sorts of dogs interior and
stuff oh screwed really like the leather
you can't say the letter no but that's
the least of your worries
the engine all the the drivetrain the
chassis that's what you're worried about
but you're right about the concept the
content is like I've seen other people
do like a luxury car or not luxury uh
what do you call super cars super cars
and they they put them like jump them
off and Destroy them but the views they
get from that they'll make more money
off of Just that's what I was telling
Jam like even though he paid let's 575
000 let's say he does this over a year
and he documents it what she's doing and
he has a big YouTube channel that dude's
gonna make more money off right just
that covers the 575 that he paid so then
the rest is just salvaging that and
let's say he puts a mill somebody pay
over milk they make more money yeah it's
a smart move yep dude how about this
this dog okay have you seen this clip
yet or not what is it so this okay
Dynamics dog it's a Boston Dynamics dog
this is the the fighter problem in New
York and they use this for the I think
this is one of the first times you use
it for because you know the parking
garage collapsed so they're looking for
survivors people that are injured or
whatever because it's too dangerous to
walk in there if you're you know you
know a cop or a fire you're paying like
a Dalmatian but check it out so look how
it moves
it's pretty badass right
I think the other firefighters make fun
of One firefighter in a uh n95 mask
it's like hey [__] you don't we're
gonna look for a bomb you're worried
about covet yeah so they use it here and
here's footage though this is what's
disappointing I'll show you right now
this is it looks and on top of that
watch as soon as it enters you'll see
it looks like he doesn't want to do it
well I mean they're controlling it
but watch this
tell me to get stuck boom it just Falls
it's like my son's toys are like Dad I
want this my dudes come from China
disaster and it comes like
they always look cool I'm like they can
do everything but if you see this I'm
like oh gosh they just I don't know dude
remember guys go risk his life to get
back on track that's really funny by the
way you're supposed to have like tank
tracks like why would it walk like a
[__] dog have tank Drive yeah
apparently though it's got it can do
crazy stuff like the robots are crazy it
can't even go up the [__] ramp Bud
apparently it sucks apparently it
apparently it's a complete waste of
taxpayers money right send a real dog in
there
or just like a tiny little drone with a
camera you just fly through all like
little compete in actual yeah those
lines they send those guys they'll do
them yeah they can do crazy stuff right
like you're going too fast dumbass
so this has been a a viral thing that
people are wondering if this because
this is considered cheating or not so
Chance the Rapper was at a uh Carnival
you know that dance crazy thing yeah
well I mean he's in carnival
Caribbean his whole entire last album
was centered around being faithful to
his girl I know but he's in carnival
wait this is Brazil yeah so so let's see
look at her too she's Brazilian
so he's doing this he's humping her from
behind with clothes on but it's in a
line my wife would kill me so he's
married yeah so he's married
uh so people are saying like dude he's
married without is this considered
cheating and people said that in this
thing that you do here everyone dances
like this and they know we don't [__]
each other they just move on yeah it's
like doing the luau in Hawaii it's just
like what I mean he's like oh she's
gorgeous and I guarantee his wife was
like Hey [__] face what are you doing
look at his look at his bodyguard his
bodyguard's like man those cameras
everywhere bro
and you know look he looks like camera
like oh you're filming that look at his
face though yeah look at her she's out
yeah I think she's the one that posted
this too so
um yeah do you guys yeah I mean
obviously it's not cheating but if you
guys had a wife I mean you guys have
wives and
she was the one on the receiving end
would you be like hey well chance hasn't
been doing any push-ups so that's what
I'm gonna say
he didn't wrestle he's not like super
yeah chance and you have the same
incline bench but hey dude um come on
yeah I think the thing with him too is
he's really religious too so that's why
he gets so much blowback like he's super
religious so I think that's frowned upon
I don't know how that works all right he
said clearly some of you all don't know
anything about the carnival or the
culture so it's just yeah it's like when
in Rome I mean that's why I asked you
guys like my girl would be like if I
told my girl hey I'm going to Spain to
run the Bulls yeah and there's a video
me getting stabbed by a bull she'd be
like yeah that makes sense well but if
you if I go to Carnival and I'm like I'm
going to Carnival and then we looked up
the videos and I was like you know it's
a good chance I'm gonna dance and this
girl's gonna twerk on my dick like Pete
Davidson she'd be like okay okay but
that would be if you were like this
you know but if you were like this
if you were like yeah
yeah yeah yeah your lips are going yeah
he's trying yeah she might have a thing
yeah she might get a little upset about
that so it's the face you're making
his face right there he's about to bust
a hole he's inside of her it depends on
how low you're going because that's it
is boxed all jammed up look at it
this situation you keep your shirt on
though Carl or not though if you have a
body like that I would say yes
but you guys would not be cool with your
girls being the reason why girls doing
the twerking yeah
um I mean uh I it depends if she's at
carnival
if she's at caramel everyone's doing
that I'd be like yeah yeah your girl
also has one of the Seven Wonders yeah
her asses her asses yeah he should be
illegal well there should be chalk and
tape around it when she walks around
she's probably the next one to catch
footage of a drone if the aliens are
captured that's 100 true
uh yeah so uh do you want to see like a
really bad one real quick I said that to
Joanna once someone says the ain't he
married questions are laughable Carnival
cultures yeah get wine and move on
nothing that's why it's a debate that
yeah that's why but also she must have
been cool with him going to Carnival
that'd be like my girl being like yeah
I'm fine if you go to Magic City in
Atlanta and then a video comes out
making a lap dance she's like how dare
you yeah like she if yeah she knows
what's going down
yeah well she might say that when you
come home I'd like to be there depends
what kind of video it is
yeah all right this is a bad one but I I
think you'll be interested in this run
so there's a woman that found someone
that looked like her on Instagram she
hit up other different girls as well but
she found this one and then
her and her boyfriend met up with her
she's gonna give her some beauty
supplies because this girl's like a
beauty vlogger they ended up stabbing
her 50 plus times and killed her and put
it into her car to make it look like she
died so she wanted to fake her own death
because she had issues with her own
family insurance so she wanted to fake
her own death and killed this person
I'm assuming the girl on the left with
the filters the one who killed the hot
one on the right yes that's what's going
down this is the most insane poor girl
dude imagine losing like a daughter or a
girlfriend or your wife because this
crazy [__] wanted to fake her own death
and she looked hey they don't look
similar one's ugly one's cool and they
shared up multiple girls but she they
were able to get it that's terrible man
that's absolutely so terrible very young
this girl both 23 stabbed to death by
these scumbags like what kind of people
are these did they forget about DNA I
mean some people are so bad I can't grow
up to him let's say police were baffled
out of learning the victim was not sure
Ben K the person that pretended
initially suspected
they looked into their social media
correspondence find that she had
connected multiple look-alikes they
formed the theory that she had murdered
one of the women wild bid to fake her
own death this woman is such a weirdo
she's a track down arrested of course
this week she's officially started with
murder faces prison if found guilty of
gruesome crime what a scumbag what a
terrible this is the one that was
murdered what is this beautiful poor
girl my that's tragic and you you have
some scumbag she's dumb as [__] to begin
with like what a dumb what a dumb
[__] plan and what a what a more a
moral human being the victim was killed
with more than 50 stablings that's crazy
badly injured because they of course
they wanted to you know that was brutal
in the extreme
it was an extraordinary case that
required all the mascara skills we don't
have a case like this every day
especially with such spectacular twist
Jesus poor family
I mean over that over some
crazy yeah that's terrible bring this
let's switch it up but you see that if
you go back Jenny see it says uh
uh I said Katy Perry she got booed on
the last American Idol because that girl
on the right for people she's she's from
Georgia like you know not Atlanta
Georgia she's from Georgia oh yeah and
uh she can sing her ass off
but she like puts too much like a sex
appeal out there and Katie from the very
jumps like you can sing girl let that
speak for you quit doing all the tit and
ass shaking you don't need to do all
that yeah totally at the very beginning
she didn't put it that way but she put
it like that way so then at the live one
uh in Hawaii which is like the you know
when the fans can vote she goes back to
old ways and she's shaking and yelling
doing her ass and Katie was like I told
you just sing you can [__] sing crowd
starts booner in case like this first
time I've ever been booted on the show
in six years she goes I'm telling you
I'm right here she has the chops where
she doesn't need to do the you know all
the sexy stuff just [__] scene girl
she can sing man but Kitty also does
sexually explicit stuff too right I mean
suggestives
you should take her no she should take a
note because it took away from her
Talent yeah I didn't see what and that's
not gonna like get her move or get be
the winner was it overly crazy it was a
lot yeah it was just a lot more grace
yeah but that's what she had more grace
yeah
good old TV you're a TV guy you watch TV
I'm TV current event guy gives me a lot
to talk about because I do many shows
you know how you came here I was like
what am I going to talk about yeah
amateur yeah what do you got chin really
so you watch uh should we end it on this
nice one your little popcorn well it's
only what's Sunday and Mondays I miss
Mondays [__] up all right what is this
so Paige spiranac have you know you know
this girl she's like uh you've never
heard of her Jesus she's very famous in
the golf Community because she does that
oh I know she's labeled the most
beautiful woman on earth right which is
all potentially
yeah I know
so I can't play the audio but then uh so
she got a lot of flack for obviously
posing in like really nice revealing
clothing and doing golf stuff
she gives you golf lessons I don't see
the problem here
yeah she's super hot obviously
um so just okay lift her head up just
okay
so anyways after all the Flack she
responded with this video
pink boobs
whatever on those boobs boobs are great
simple as that I just thought it's like
a little she's just leaning into it yeah
clearly she knows why she's making money
wait wait what happened though why did
she get why was she taking heat I guess
for this particular Tick Tock but just
all of her videos all the video like
she's ridiculously hot and then she's
like giving golf lessons yeah so people
are pissed off I'm sure mostly women are
pissed off about her especially in golf
I think they're golf but this is good
for golf dude oh yeah fellas I'll wait
name a professional female golfer go
ahead
uh but Brian just one go ahead
that's such an unfair question man it's
so disrespectful to ask me that question
you can name her though I can name her
what else you got to uh last one Georgie
fish tank
well that's pretty yeah there's actual
real fish in there too hey Brandon look
fish although I feel like they don't
have much to swim in that's a real
shallow pool it's long though you know
what it's about the the length fish
prefer the length oh if the length is
good you're good is that light though on
them all the time bad that's not good
yeah they're gonna die early yeah yeah
it's bad so if there's a lot of light
and then also a lot of uh stimulus like
people constantly walking up to the bar
those fish die early so notice that the
[__] fish they have in there yeah
there's like betas and Tetris fish you
can just replace those all the time yeah
because it's not constantly thing now
when you go into like which is always
weird to me when you go into the sushi
place and that behind the bar is a giant
sea water aquarium salt water aquarium
dude 200 Grand just in that like legit
fish like holy [__] but those fish
aren't going to have longevity there's
too much steamless lights are always on
them they leave the lights on like and
it [__] up their their circadian rhythm
because they turn the lights on to what
maybe 6 p.m turn off at 1am sometimes so
those fish die early it's not a good
thing for they should make that illegal
if you care about the fish yeah that's
all she had a sushi joint
is that is that is that not offensive
yeah you can get fish and chips at
SeaWorld well because Sea World you
think about the mammals not the fish
right well if you're a human being you
care about fish steam out all the fish
I don't care about fish
I know you're you have a soft spot for
them but I'm probably gonna go eat a
salmon right piece of salmon though
eating salmon now
if it was deep fried whale would you
care if they're like hey you know we
have killer whales menu I wouldn't need
a well you know what it's a mammal
that's trivia question before we sign
off what is it I know what is a gray
whale or any whale do when the old
killer whales show up how does it
protect himself
besides leaving
can't leave can't swim as fast they go
deep nope I like that good answer good
answer might be might be one of the
things they do but yeah I know some go
deep the ones that can go deeper go deep
Maybe
what else they do
I know the beluga whale for the to
protect the babies from uh killer whales
and like polar bears the uh babies are
born like dark so they hide in the
shadow of the mother so the the other
fish can't see them they don't pick it
up so they get away
what is it Brian they turn over on their
back because they're dead no no because
then they would eat them no because they
the whales can't get through that thick
hide
because their bellies are soft yeah
because the killer whales attack the
bellies and they just turn over and
start swimming to the great white goes
look at this dumbass up top gray off the
ropes whales don't give a [__] about
great whites yeah it is interesting
right
all right buddy what do you got look
Portland Helium Comedy Club I think
we're almost sold out already I got
Comedy Zone Port Charlotte Florida May
four five six and seven nope May four
five and six where's part short where's
Port Charlotte near Naples uh Saratoga
uh you haven't done you've done it the
vasani theater
Charlotte no no you have no never never
uh
uh New Brunswick New Jersey Stress
Factory baby let's go hey B is is Port
Charlotte the same uh your throat
problem is the Port Charlotte the same
fan base as Naples
no no younger younger different yeah
I'll answer how far is it from Naples uh
hour and a half okay so weighs out yeah
huh hour 20. something like that
interesting uh nothing on the books till
uh June 2nd La Jolla June 2nd through
the 4th is La Jolla comic store one of
the best clubs in the nation and then
June 15th through the 25th your boys
over across the pond starting uh in
Belfast June 15th one show in each City
at the theater run so it's Belfast
Glasgow Manchester London Cardiff Dublin
I end in Dublin that's on June 25th one
show only in every city Big Boy theater
run so come get you something we're
going bigboy.com we're going down to our
front for 10 days everybody should know
that
I mean when I bang some dude we're
trying to figure it out try to bank some
all right kids love you we're out